it's interesting that uh in Gaza
Palestine they had the 51-day war
because I want to make Palestine the
51st American state whoa I think this is
the solution we're just here to offend
everybody with show I want to make life
good good for those people I want to
make it a high-tech place where people
can Thrive and communicate with their
neighbors and live in peace we can have
trade unions all work and it can be
Islamic in nature it'll be wonderful I
think I think Ian's probably just being
a little a little hyperbolic to sh
people absolutely look I think it's fair
to say no matter who you are we want
peace in the Middle East we want peace
in the world